what's our depth
the desiree is 4 000 feet below sea
level captain
nice and easy now lander softly
we have video
bring it up
holy sh
we were at the west mata volcano 140
miles southwest of samoa
here
this volcano although thousands of feet
beneath the water's surface
3937 feet to be exact
this volcano although
3937 feet beneath the water surface is
still actively spewing out liquid hot
magma
in fact many of the world's most active
volcanoes are underwater
let's get will on the line
dr sager hi
how's tamu massif still
messy
it's still big still the biggest volcano
in the world do we know about captain
costello well tell me more dr sager well
tamu massif is really really big it
stands two and a half miles tall over
the ocean bottom but it's really really
wide it's 120 000 square miles an
we lost him
what will is saying is that tamu massif
is extremely stout despite being 2.5
miles tall
around submarine volcanoes you often
find hydrothermal vents they're like hot
springs where temperatures can reach up
to 750 degrees fahrenheit
even when the surrounding waters are
near freezing
and they're teeming with life from
lobsters to octopi crabs and worms
even in the filiginous deep ocean
amidst intense volcanic activity
life
finds a way
unbelivable
you